yeah let's facetiming right now shut up
my guy what are you doing it's not gonna
dance his [ __ ] ass off I'll tell you
all about it when I see you you got your
prospectus send me in flight from New
York to alight here for the digital
upfront for pure Wow and 137 p.m. we're
going to some event snails promoting all
our things for 2019 so that advertisers
and brands can get excited and spend
with us and then we'll take some
potential and current clients out to
dinner vid summit keynote so should be a
good day
137 p.m. i'm gary vaynerchuk I've been
an entrepreneur my whole life over the
last three to five years what has
probably become apparent to a lot of
people in this room is that
entrepreneurship has been put on a
cultural pedestal and navigating through
the media and advertising landscape as I
have it became very obvious to me that
the way I live my life and many others
which is entrepreneurship being the
thing that I most identify with being
the filter that I take sports or fashion
or any parts of culture through became a
white space that a lot of people weren't
really addressing 137 pm's commissioned
in 2019 is to continue establishing what
it's been able to do we're looking to
build massive pillars that we think are
ownable for the brands associated with
those executions whether it's the 30
most entrepreneurial athletes whether it
is Superbowl whether it is a series of a
calling face-to-face time takes your
attention hope the day's going well I'm
sure it's long
I have to see something soon thank you
oh wait Ryan you're taking pictures with
talent talent palette and one weird
executive Neil who's facetiming right
now see if we can get him you love him
he's amazing my dude my guy what are you
doing where are you
that's what's up you're in a studio
where you just say what's up to my guy
say what's up I'm a big fan
this guy can dance his [ __ ] ass off
I'll tell you all about it when I see
you you've been good I'm in LA I just
did an upfront with my guy here you
opened for our media company that 137
p.m. that new site where I'm like just
gonna write a ton of [ __ ] about you I'll
tell you all that away I see you next
man I've been watching man I'm real
happy for him and I'm so [ __ ] proud
for you dude I'm so proud of you my game
I'm gonna be in Atlanta Bunch I was
gonna be in Atlanta for Superbowl and
I'm gonna be in New York in LA a whole
bunch in the next couple months send you
up
[Music]
[ __ ] mugs
coffee mugs Hammond's coffee mugs their
every [ __ ] garage shut for 20 [ __ ]
five cents and they're all worth for 230
dollars it's [ __ ] ridiculous
stuffed animals and coffee mugs are more
likely to get these stuffed animals and
coffee mugs are more likely to get the
ninety nine percent to the police they
want to get to then their [ __ ]
[ __ ] brand streetwear brand and
[ __ ] startup app that's the [ __ ]
truth for 99 percent of you watching
right now
for the twenty five hundred of you that
are live right now for 99 percent of you
that are trying to get to a hundred
thousand a year it's a quicker path an
easier path I'm more likely path that
you go to garage sales yard sales flea
markets and Goodwill's
and buy [ __ ] ceramic coffee mugs and
[ __ ] stuffed animals and flip your
way to a hundred thousand then building
the next supreme or Instagram
that's [ __ ] facts wriggle out much
louder
[Music]
how you doing good phone so far are you
how you doing I'm sorry this is the
greatest thing or a fake
entrepreneurship what's funny even if
you look at where I'm getting excited
about content I'm like trying to I'm
like pushing people more to go like
garage saleing and like make a thousand
bucks yeah I'm like literally there's so
many reasons why it's happening first of
all I just seriously think that going
garage selling might be my favorite
thing on earth like yeah we openly like
this is actually this is crazy I just
remembered we almost fit it on revision3
yeah that's right I think me and AJ
almost did this is real we almost did
trash talk literally what I did this Sat
laughs like two weeks ago on revision3
nine years ago
I wish kids and I wish he knew how
[ __ ] young you are given was it
started yeah how old are you like I
would rip my arm off and give up
everything I have to be 19 that's how
much advantage time is it's the asset
and so to be this far along and think
this entrepreneurial and have this
Internet at this maturity like right
like if I grew up if I was a 15 year old
right now I'd be first of all I would
have never graduated high school my
second of all I would be a booking
grillionaire and be the happiest [ __ ]
of all time a garage sale all day long
I've been making like 97 million a year
buying stuff on [ __ ] at flea markets
and flipping it is I want everyone in
this room to get value out of this talk
and I'm not sure if there's anything
else I can say better than what I'm
about
and I really need you to understand it
the big advantage that everybody here
like myself that over 40 has is we've
lived through an economic meltdown we've
lived through it
thus we anticipate it in a different way
than if you're under 32 you can't
because if you only lived life
professionally in an environment where
the economy has been flourishing you
don't realize what happens which is
literally tomorrow morning you can wake
up and we can have a Bear Stearns some
sort of event that completely starts the
collapse of the economy and all of a
sudden the DMS from a detox tea or from
Pepsi or Coach stop let me tell you what
stops when the economy collapses people
don't just want to buy a $22 t-shirt
that has a funny saying big brands don't
want to pour money because they don't
have it into the market context in
understanding what's happening right now
in the global economy this is all
growing but it's growing during a time
of frothy massive economic growth so if
you're sitting here and your strategy is
I'm gonna get off my job and I'm gonna
get into this or I'm now making 80k and
you're doing this but I'm about to go to
a half a million
you have to contextualise the moment
we're in I Cal entrepreneurs all the
time and I don't want to razz here but I
want everybody wrap their head around it
if you're not crushing it right now as
an entrepreneur you suck
[Applause]
you everybody here if you're lucky
enough to have a very elderly family
member and or if you just want to give
back and go to a retirement home go
spend time with I think the reason I
have wisdom is from a very young age for
who knows why as a kid I would go to the
playground and my friends would have
like our grandparents visit and you know
this is just down to like DNA like
unexplainable [ __ ] I would like run off
the playground and like sit with like 80
year olds and be like ask random ass
[ __ ] I've always been so gravitating
towards that what it taught me is the
only thing I don't want to have is
regret regret is poison it's poison so
like I'd rather lose and have all of you
laugh at me then sit at 91 on a bench
and be like [ __ ] I really wish I had
that person follow me around with the
camera or or whatever it may be you know
so like just don't have regret cool
awesome take care everyone thanks
everyone
[Music]
I think I think where you are in your
career right now you do a song with a
crossover Main Street Walmart big brand
person when I say branded human I think
it would change the course cigarette
what Kendrick did and he was further
along at that point when he did it
but when Kendrick when I saw Kendrick
put out a song with Taylor Swift
like four years ago I was like game over
game over it's what it's it's smart now
you've just now to me the question
becomes you know is there something
actually authentic you know what I would
do if I were you straight up I would
start listening to the radio while
you're driving around just if you hear
something you be like yo who's that and
be like who the [ __ ] is whatever you see
where I'm going
stand away it's authentic then you're
like yo I [ __ ] with this song you know
what I mean like exactly just or just
take the top 100 on Spotify and just
[ __ ] listen to it when you're living
and be like oh that sounds that and it's
like some rock band or some pop girl and
then you can be authentic to you because
they need you to
[Music]